well you know obviously the public has a
great interest when an earthquake
happens and so we do our best best we
can the questions tend to be repetitive
almost always we get a question from
somebody about whether they can come see
the Richter scale do we have an example
of the Richter scale the Richter scale
is of mathematical calculation in fact
seismologists don't use it anymore the
only reason we give a Richter magnitude
frankly is for the press and the media
but we have much better ways of
measuring the energy of an earthquake
now but the second question that's
cropped up and it's fascinating in its
own right is that the first time I heard
it I thought it was a fluke but I've
heard it so many times since Haiti that
I wonder what's going on that is are
these earthquakes related to global
warming I'm serious about that I'd say
that most of the press and most of the
public that have called in that that
didn't have specific domain knowledge
has asked us that question we also got
questions whether you know 2012 is
coming a couple years early we get that
sort of thing it's just the end of days
but I think it speaks to something more
interesting which is that earthquakes
and major disasters I have a certain
impact on the public consciousness and I
think earthquakes more so or even
volcanic eruptions more so than than
anything else you know we get a major
hurricane a few major hurricanes every
year we get floods every year there are
major disasters that caused an enormous
amount of economic damage and casualties
but yet we hear about them relatively
often and so we kind of think of that as
kind of background this is what the
earth is doing to us but earthquakes
especially major ones are relatively
rare we get a few major ones a decade
particularly ones with huge numbers of
casualties and and the concept of an
earthquake that it shakes the firmament
that that that it removes your footing
that it could destroy everything in a
blink of an eye and that it is
unpredictable that it just
happens even if your rationale in a
scientific way even if you're rational
and even a theological sort of way you
get a it has to have some impact you
know the the response the scientific
response to the chile earthquake
although modulated a bit by the damage
and by the casualties still was this is
a major earthquake we've got to look at
this as well as we can because we only
get a couple of shots a decade to look
at this so now there are teams of
scientists and lots of instrumentation
going to Chile but when you get down to
Haiti or something like Haiti when you
get a directed on a capital city when
the the bulk of the nation is affected
where you have damage that far exceeds
their economic ability to to come back
coupled with the fact that an earthquake
literally moves the ground on which your
cited you start asking basic questions
like should I even be here should I be
living here do I have to move what is
what is the future of my country what is
the future of my city and those are
sorts of questions I things have such a
big impact on the public that by
necessity I think we've got to talk
about them we've got to talk about what
it means I think science is somewhat ill
equipped to do that we quantify
everything we enumerate the energies the
displacements the ground motion we have
we have technology and we have lingo but
none of this relates to somebody who's
asking the question my house was
destroyed where should I move it relates
of course in a very quantitative
scientific way but how do you how do you
approach that person how do you assure
them that the situation has a rational
response now I don't think we have a
good way to deal with that so a lot of
the questions we were getting and a lot
of the
thinking that generated had to do with
these central questions of what does
this mean particularly for the future of
Haiti but what does this mean when we
talk about taking steps to mitigate
against future tragedy future disasters
not just for earthquakes what for the
other major natural disasters as well
and to me that and many of us i should
say it's not that we haven't thought
about this before but it seems to me to
be an area not just of research but of
so it's sort of a way to link directly
to the public directly to the people who
need to understand what it is we're
doing as scientists and I could I can
make the same sort of argument about
climate change for example but the
earthquakes serve I use a phrase and I
don't mean to use it lightly but
earthquake service training days for the
major environmental disasters major
environmental stresses that our planet
faces and if we can begin to address how
we relate to the public how we provide
assurance how we help the public to
understand what it is it happening them
if we can understand how to do that for
major earthquakes or major hurricanes
then perhaps we can do something about
stuff that's even more merger the major
more in the future more emergent more
probabilistic where we actually might
have a chance in modifying our behavior
to do something about it so what I've
taken away from this interaction from
Haiti and it's and Chile and I must
admit it's not new to this earthquake
we've had it before with the Indonesian
earthquake in the indian ocean tsunami
we've seen it earthquakes going as far
back as the 80s and the 70s and places
like Armenia and shine and so on but
what we've taken away from this is that
there's a conversation that scientists
have to have with the public that the
public will regard as deep
meaningful which means we can't just
throw our results over the fence we
can't just stick with our technical
journals there's got to be some other
mechanism and in my view I think
universities where we ascribe to liberal
thinking the small L liberal you know we
ought to that ought to be a good place
to do it and i think the universities
have that kind of role to play beyond
the roles that governments and other
social institutions play